what did you think about that crazy ship
with Conor McGregor throwing the dolly
at the bus you know I'm giving a corner
a lot of passes and the only reason I'm
giving them a lot of passes the same as
Mike Tyson it's like you know you're
getting a lot of money you have the
wrong people around you everybody's a
Yeasayer you know if somebody says hey
you know what we should we should throw
something against the bus the whole gang
is gonna yeah let's do that sounds great
idea you know I think you just got
caught up in the moment you know be him
try to be him he can't go anywhere he
can't pump gas he can't do it everybody
recognizes he's got a lot of pressure on
him I think he just has to figure
himself out and it's gonna be okay deep
down inside he's a good guy you don't
like him and and away with his family
and his wife and everything that he does
I hope he never loses that because that
made him love him yeah me look at it
this way like ray Borg was on that bus
oh I know he got his eyes cut you got
corneal abrasions cuz Connor threw that
dolly at the bus and I mean who knows
what's gonna happen to Ray's eyes see if
you can find an update on that ray
Borg's condition because he was the most
one who suffered the most serious injury
michael Chiesa got cut on his head and
is that but that I think he's okay I
think those are just cuts and he'll be
fine but Ray Bourg that you know you get
a corneal abrasion that's really that's
really serious you know what I was gonna
say it'll imagine if the roles were
reversed yeah magic Connor was on the
bus and Ray Bourque threw a [ __ ]
thing here UFC ray board yesterday's
show to cut below his eye it's in his
eyeball Oh
Conor McGregor talking a bus he had a
number of other MMA stars he and another
a number of other MMA stars are seated
on so yeah so he's got he's got some
seriously ray Porter's only 24 you know
I'm a what I was afraid of is that
somebody's gonna assume just like heaven
with Russell Crowe we remember when he
hit the guy with the telephone in his
face they had to settle it for like six
or eight million dollars because
otherwise it was going to go to court
and if it goes to court he's got a
felony can never fight in two in America
again that means for Russell Crowe could
have never done a movie in America again
so he had to settle with the guy and he
had to give him that money that's a lot
of money there guys probably balling
right now yeah it's probably right now
sitting on a beach somewhere and
drinking a margarita
go Russell Crowe well it depends if he
never had money it's probably gone
you know yeah taxes gonna blow my
[ __ ] fantasy had a beautiful fantasy
this guy with his feet up on the beach
pina colada something with an umbrella
in it yeah and it's all gone now and now
he said he's cleaning making shoeshine
and then it's to make his money still in
paradise because he couldn't buy a
ticket back what I was gonna say is
imagine if the roles were reversed
imagine it was ray Borg through the
dolly in a cut Conor McGregor's oh
listen I'm not I'm not saying that it's
good I'm not now first of all he didn't
do it on purpose but I understand what
you're saying I'm just saying I'm
looking at not Conor McGregor I look at
what happened to him the last two years
and that's a lot to deal with you know
and I think he has to sort that out and
I think that the picture this morning I
with his baby and his life was there you
could tell on his face that he don't
watch something like he he was polite he
was like a shame for you watch the
picture you know I've seen so you keep
out of jail it's entirely possible that
they might put him in jail yeah that
would be not good and because if it's a
felony he's gonna have a problem getting
into America right oh yeah that's what I
mean it's a very dangerous I mean what
do they do here for his career if he
he's gotta settle so if he settles with
michael Chiesa who already filed a
lawsuit against him
or you already filed us some sort of a
complaint our charges something so him
and ray Borg for certain is gonna do the
same thing so those who were cut
everybody else on the bus every other
fighter on the bus could sue for
emotional damage oh yeah
they can't one including Rose thugz Rose
was gonna pull out of the fight yeah she
was really considering pulling out of
the fight she was so shooken up you know
the thing that I I do like it that he at
least because when he talked to Dana day
he didn't apologize but he apologized
for all the people who were on board
right he said no for the fighters I'm so
sorry so I'm happy he did that you know
but it's something he can't turn back he
can you can make it right what you can
you can try to make it right like a
band-aid on a wound but you know to give
them all hell I would say give the guy a
little space and then hopefully he'll
figure it out and he'll settle it with
those guys some would say that the only
way for him to really learn is to face
consequences for his actions and if you
just keep giving them space is gonna
just keep pushing them needle
he's gonna keep doing more [ __ ] up
things like no but that will happen now
right he's gonna go he's gonna have to
pay he's going to have to pay 100%
guarantee he was doesn't want to go to
court like he's got a hundred million
dollars and he made from that fight yeah
but he still and with the taxes and
everything of and with everything he's
buying and all you know I mean let's say
he's got thirty million left yeah let's
say he's got thirty million left taxes
all that other jazz what you really get
versus what they say you get it is a lot
going on there right yeah the training
expenses bought a house bought a couple
of Bentleys depth or uh he's gonna give
out a few million here yep this is gonna
cost him a few million that's right I'm
minimally but if you look at the Russell
Crowe the whole thing plus if they
really were going to do this Floyd
Mayweather thing they're not gonna be
able to do it now yep
I mean if he gets arrested or he is
arrested but if he gets convicted and
they wind up putting him in jail it's
entirely like mean he's got charged with
assault mischief a few other different
things
he's enough L in the charges yeah well I
mean it's entirely possible that there
could be some real serious consequences
for this and if they really were gonna
do that but how many people would pay to
see that mayweather fight in the Octagon
you know but it give us a little bit of
stupid rules it goes from the mayweather
fight it's like almost Enochian when he
fought Ali right just before they said
no more kicks above the way or no more
kicks above the waist yeah no needs no
grappling techniques I mean they charge
changing the rules just an hour two
hours before so so what would you like
to see them fight if they need an inch
do it with knees knees and elbows kill
him I know but that's what I want to say
I mean even if there's no grappling
Conor will kill him it's just with kicks
yeah give them kicks he'll take his legs
out just be no kicks even just low